the dark urban challenge promises to be
a stage for innovation in the areas of
Robotics perception and planning mit has
assembled a team of top researchers in
these fields and is determined to win
the Grand Challenge with that in mind
mit has chosen the land rover lr3
because of its unique on and off-road
capabilities the vehicle will rely upon
a layered sensor architecture that will
incorporate a couple GPS AI NS system a
series of redundant lidar scanners or
short to medium-range sensing and
several telephoto and wide field cameras
that will be used for object detection
in the near and far field while capable
hardware is necessary the unique nature
of the upcoming challenge places the
greatest responsibility on software and
winning will require a revolution in the
approach to the problems ranging from
perception to planning whether you are
in Baghdad or Boston uncertainty is
implicit in all aspects of urban driving
the driver must constantly be aware of a
pedestrian darting out onto the street
or the car ahead suddenly braking as
well as replan routes on the fly to deal
with unexpected road construction
uncertainty will similarly extend to all
aspects of the DARPA Grand Challenge MIT
will take advantage of its unique
research in statistical state estimation
in mapping planning under uncertainty
and statistical perception in developing
a software architecture that addresses
uncertainty at all levels of the
perception planning and control tasks at
the high level our architecture will
include a mission planner that manages
the global plan a situational planner
that is designed to rapidly handle the
uncertainty of the environment and a
perceptual state estimator that extracts
alien information from the scene a map
fragment database maintains a history of
the relevant scene structure and allows
the technical planner to be more
aggressive when revisiting areas this
simulation shows a motion planning
technique applied to a sample rdf under
nominal conditions the planner chooses
the shortest path to the goal but is
able to replan on the fly when an
obstruction arises in the multi vehicle
case our algorithms predict the motion
of other agents and replan short horizon
trajectories in order to avoid
conflicting paths the path planning
relies on a condensed description of the
environment provided by the sensors
similarly our current Vision Research is
capable of real-time 3d tracking of
features and shapes
which then provides rich and sailing
information about the environment with
video we identify long-range movement
with particles that capture motion that
is spatially dense and temporally
long-range the obstacles can then be
tracked using robust and optimized
vision methods that take into account
the structure of the scene in this
mock-up the system separates the road
shown in blue from the obstacle shown in
red and extracts in the far field a sign
which in turn impacts the driving
behavior additionally the mapping
component of the system will draw upon
our current research and localization
and mapping which has been demonstrated
in large complex environments mit in
conjunction with Olin College currently
has the skills and hardware development
and construction necessary to implement
these unique algorithms work by team
members previously at the iRobot
corporation demonstrates the ability to
deploy autonomous vehicles that operate
in rugged outdoor terrain common both to
on-road and urban driving puddles are
one challenging feature as they are not
easily detected by standard laser
rangefinder technology driving in an
urban environment will require highly
precise navigation at the local scale
using the navcomm system we can
accurately control the vehicle based
upon an IMU and by directly
incorporating occasional GPS data can
achieve centimeter precision here the
system uses the vehicles own motion to
recover three-dimensional information
from the planar laser range data of the
vehicle some vehicle poses can cause a
ground plane to appear as an obstacle to
the system here we show that the vehicle
slows down in order to ensure that the
perceived obstacle during the downward
pitches in fact the ground plane before
continuing in high speed part of the
DARPA challenge requires the ability to
park between stationary on modeled
vehicles here we see a vehicle
demonstrating a similar ability by
autonomously pulling into an orchard
land using a fusion GPS lidar wheel
odometry envision GPS is used to
identify the approximate location of the
lane opening after which local sensors
take over for navigation another
critical capability required for the
DARPA challenge is sensing and tracking
of other moving vehicles here we see the
ATV tracking the moving vehicles ahead
of it using only a single laser
rangefinder and a color camera mit is a
long-standing history of building
autonomous platforms for a wide range of
environments that have successfully
helped to pave the way for the maturing
field of robotics we are looking forward
to applying our technical
experience to the 2006 DARPA urban
challenge